allerdings sieht eure mal wasser und
willkommen zu einer neuen folge
worldwide wohnzimmer viel besser und
zwar seine wills wissen
ihr dürft mich heute magic warnen denn
denn ja ein magie zauber sperren
das ist ganz einfach das ist ein
schweres aber und heute jetzt mal hier
ein paar tricks war
ich habe da schon mal sehen wen ihr
guckt und wie es noch nie ganz wie das
funktioniert auf jeden fall braucht
batterien satz und magische batterien
und diesen kampf also den anders als
normale batterien die sind halt
magischen also das magische kraft
reingepackt worden und es ist halt
kriegt man nicht so wenn man also beim
namen youtuber ist schon dann kriegt man
die man hat alles bekommt was man bilder
zu liebe aber hier quasi nicht außer
mirella oder so schon zu mir du würdest
sie bekommen aber der rest hat nicht
also das ist unser zauberstab
präparieren mal ganz kurz also ein
zauberer verriet ja nie seine tipps
tricks tipps und tricks deshalb kann ich
euch leider nicht verraten wie das ganze
so funktioniert aber seid gespannt
ja also am das ist mein magischen
zauberstab sowie laserschwert und jetzt
werde ich gerade angerufen
und jetzt werde ich nicht mehr angerufen
das war mein zaubershow also hier für
meine magischen flugobjekte drin die
hole ich jetzt mal ganz kurz raus einen
moment okay leute weiße blätter wäre
komplett geflasht sein okay seht ihr
dieses ding hat doch jeder zu hause oder
ja dann seht mal her versuche immer zwei
magischer schwere zauber 3 seht ihr sie
das schwer
überwinde die schwerkraft weg mich
einmal gescheitert aber wir haben ja
noch mehr flugobjekte zauberhut seit ich
schon gespannt ja abrakadabra sind
seinem floß tempo zaubertrick irgendwann
später
warten sie gehen sie noch nicht dieses
objekt wird gleich in die luft gehen
wow hallo leute klasse ein
schmetterlinge fliegen
ihr seht ihr könnt mich sehen auch von
uns finanzierte werbung
wenn ich gerade eine 22 jährige die mit
einem pub zauberstab spielt ok bis mal
die macht des zauberstab überhaupt erst
einen zauberstab auffüllen
faszinierend wie ein luftballon der mit
helium gefüllt wurde
diese woche wollt ihr eure freunde
beeindrucken wenn der user
ich habe hier diese folge war der wird
wissen gefallen
das nächste mal tschüss handy hatte